hello say hi Matthew
so we work in the data engineering team
at man font technology so we're going to
talk to you a little bit today about how
we use data
how are you technology and have a
combination of the two effectively
powers our system and trading business
so what we're gonna my throat is I'll
give you a quick overview of what the
business actually is what we actually do
we'll go through the actual data that we
use I'll tell you how effectively how it
flows the old fight through our pipes
and we store huge amounts of data and
finally we will go into how we actually
use it so to start with so we are low to
medium frequency systematic traders so
what that means is we systematic traders
that means that we are buying and
selling securities in a systematic
fashion we do not have discretionary
traders who are taking the view of the
market and deciding what to buy and sell
instead everything is traded
systematically ie we had computers doing
it all for us we're low to medium
frequency traders what that means is the
positions that we hold we tend to hold
for between a few hours for kinda medium
frequency in today trading two weeks or
months on the more low end of the
spectrum we're not high frequency
traders we're not issuing a hundred
orders a second well you're not trying
to respond to market events like
immediately isn't our business from the
technology standpoint that means we're
not as sensitive to they can see as
people seem to think we are what we
should be so this is kind of like a very
high-level overview of the business the
main story is kind of trying to get
across is that everything starts with
data so we ingest data from the outside
and who really do do things with that
data we obviously have a team of
researchers who look at that data and
produce trading strategies and those
trading strategies also obviously one
introduction
they are also fed of the data that we
ingest from the outside and they spit
out trades so a trade is for example
buying five stocks of Google chairs or
Microsoft shares or buying natural gas
that's about that soon the strategy is
only a task your life we need is to out
it's to look at the data that's being
fitted to them and
put these rates those trades that float
through to execution this is where we
thought we find a counterparty for the
trade and certain likely to to a broker
through an exchange
execution is actually quite a complex
pipeline it's a Volvo funding minute
eyes are trading costs and ensure that
the price that we trade that is actually
the place we thought we could trade that
when the strategy was running and when
the strategy was actually looking at the
data that was being fed to it
the end goal as you can probably imagine
as we want to make profits on the trades
that we make and buy low sell high it's
yeah it's like the old adage it is kind
of that to be list so hopefully
hopefully we're going to make a profit
cool so we're going to take a look at
some of the data that we actually use so
I'm sure lots of you have seen glass
similar to this before so what this is
if this is the closing price of a stock
in this case alphabet stock every day
over the course of the entire day yeah
so the closing price is the price of the
final transaction made an exchange
before the exchange closed business that
day and so the closing price is actually
quite useful to kind of identify overall
trends over a large period of time by
year yeah but as you can imagine you can
get much higher fidelity data than that
if you imagine how an exchange actually
kind of mediates between buyers and
sellers and allows you to decide what
you what securities you actually want to
potentially buy you might come up with
what is effectively called an order book
so in exchange we'll maintain a data
structure which if you draw visually and
put up a PowerPoint slide will look a
little bit like that effectively it
keeps track of all the sell orders and
all the buy orders and orders simply
indicates what place I wants to buy
something at so how many units they want
to buy it so what what we really want is
we want this order book but we had
different we have different sorts of
tragedies some place level strategies
are only interested in what is
effectively to buy and of the bid and
the ask
so the sell order at the lowest price
has the highest priority and the Bywater
at the right place has the highest
priority
hopefully that kind of makes intuitive
sense but whoever is willing to pay the
most or whoever is willing to sell for
the least amount are going to be the
first to actually transact so some of
our strategies only care about the ask
which is the lowest
or the bed which is the highest buy in
other words we only want to see when
those two orders change other strategies
might want might want to look kind of
look at different level of data so
others might want the top three levels
in the sell side the top three levels by
side or some of our trading strategies
might actually be able to make use of
the entire order book so what we do is
we have agreements with lots of
different data vendors and they're
effectively going to stream us updates
to these order books to all the
different securities that we interested
in so what that update looks like is it
looks something like this so this is
what we call a market data tip a market
data tick is effectively an encoded
update to that order book so this
particular tick says the new bit place I
even by ordering the highest price is
32.55 it's there's now seven units
available out of place kind of place
Versa on the sell side and the last
place that was actually transacted that
was thirty point five five and five
units were transacted so this is a level
one market data stream so effectively
what that won't level all level one
means is that we're not seeing inside
view of the order book in this case this
particular stream is only giving us
updates to the bid and the ask as you
can imagine for particularly liquid
securities
we may get thousands of these updates or
films of these market data ticks every
single second and over time this
effective reforms apply series or time
series and this is what we want to be
able to store to archive and we never
really want for any other state to away
under any circumstances
yep so it kind of forms time series T
team a twenty minutes to over the course
of the day across all of our
subscriptions we process well over a
billion in particularly busy days we'll
be maybe double that there's another
side of the data story here that we're
interested in we also care about what we
call business data it's actually just
metadata for time series so for example
and the fact that what this time so
exactly affirmative alphabet in Colossae
stock a factor traded woman Nasdaq the
fact that the issue is alphabetic the
fact is the u.s. dollar denominated seed
or I'm community or two identifies no
security this is a weapons data and it's
actually really important for us to be
able to store this and to make sense of
it as without this we have absolutely no
idea what the place
is that we're looking at also the
changing over time uber is quite a good
example of this in 2015 Google Inc was
known as Google Inc them know what's
called a call to action and after that
corporate action your balls effectively
spun out as a subsidiary of alphabet we
actually want to be able to understand
how this has changed over time so when
we're looking at the time series we can
actually make sense of it and understand
that the security is referring to what
it was referring to at that point in
time so just to put a drive home how
things do change over time and how
financial relationships cream can be
quick and blacks you need to understand
this but this is just trying to get
across the message that we want to be
able to understand what we're trading
and how it relates to other things
financial initiatives can be very
complex and they can change over time
and we want to be able to effectively
query this graph at a given point in
time and see what the truth of the world
is so the high-level gameplan what were
actually trying to do is we have
effectively split environment we have a
research environment and we have a
production trading environment in
research we're going to take all of that
streaming market data and we're going to
stuff it in our you know time say we saw
which we call uptick we're going to take
the reference data we're going to put
that in a week or else with KT master
we're going to take anything else that
doesn't really fit into those two
categories so I just could have cheated
a called exotic data sets here but that
really could be anything it could be
agricultural pills it could be kind of
anonymous credit card data anything that
is going to help our researchers
identify alpha and allow us to reduce a
trading strategy which we profitable
we're going to put all of that data in
Arctic which is our long-term time
series not in research they have access
to the full view of the data and the
researchers are go to produce trading
strategies we're going to then take
their trading strategies productionize
them and put them in production where
they'll have access to a much more
limited set of that data obviously in
production they're going to then spit up
trades which are going to flow through
to execution which is what I three
fingers buy before all the way through
to the marketplace where they will
actually be transacted on so that's kind
of a very high level game plan that's
what we're gonna go through now is I'll
tell you how octave works that's outside
of time-series door and how the security
master works which
let's datastore so the security master
is where we keep our reference data it's
effectively kind of a very flexible data
linkage engine what it allows us to do
is it allows to understand lender data
and it allows us to map between
identifiers so those are identifiers for
a security ieave maybe the ticker name
or see don't or concept mapping between
identifiers sounds quite simple it's
actually quite complex and it's
incredibly important that we can do it
well because we onboard data from a
variety of different vendors generally
these vendors disagree on what naming
symbology to use and it's very important
we can understand the data when looking
at it also allows us to model financial
relationships similar to what we showed
you before so we might want to
understand what option contracts are
available against the security as well
as maybe the issue of a certain security
and we want only this to be available to
us and not have to take days or weeks to
actually get to grips with understand
it's fundamentally by temple this means
the graph that you saw before we can ask
what it looks like at a given point in
time also we can understand when that
block itself has changed
that's what's again portent in research
if you're running a long back test on
Monday Tuesday what you don't want to
happen is to see the results of that
back test changing wildly and not
understand why so we can fix this data
for given point in time so you can run
it as many times as you want and you
actually know what has changed so Arctic
is the other side of the story
security master stores reference data
they're almost static data that does
change not that often Arctic is our
solution to storing time series data it
actually is open source and that's a
github and you can check it out see if
it's something that you can use for your
projects it's it's a Python project
it focuses on storing data that's either
tech data or data frames and originally
we designed it to separate it from the
backend storage engine it has kind of
grown attached to MongoDB which is what
we use internally someone would be is
very pervasive through the Arctic but we
still keeping the idea of logical data
stores and the idea is that the API is
exposed from logical data stores are the
same so researchers can use them
easily but they store differently shaped
data they know how to deal with our data
on their optimize for the storage two
main types of the stores we use is the
version store which is specifically for
storing data frames it is just a very
fast pipeline of taking the data frame
or anything that'sthat's numpy
representable because ultimately it's a
similar thing I'm putting it through
into the the [ __ ] back-end the other
type of store is take store that's
actually for storing flowing text it is
a columnist or because simple that's
been proven as the best solution to
store taking data it's just a time frame
with relevant floats that go for the TIC
text or we are processing one two three
billion text ad a billion is something
that's average three is on the days when
announcements in May the special
American ones and across all of these
stores in our [ __ ] databases we have
over a hundred terabytes of data that we
manage and it's across all our clusters
and it's probably one of the largest
states in the world now when we designed
this we did not intend to store this
amount of data and with not intend for
this use so something that we have been
working internally for the last six
months is something we call Arctic
native it's a rewrite of the Arctic
using native techniques it's written in
C++ it comes as close to the bear Bo and
hardware as you can get it's still
exposes Python api's so our researchers
do not see the difference they only see
the difference in speed up and access
it's it's it's fairly smart in the way
it's been done and we are seeing massive
improvements as a graph we see in orders
of magnitude read faster reads and
writes better compression and we're
getting to 2gig per second both reads
and writes pair work on census C++
backends we can spin out as many workers
as you want and again Python API is
everyone's used to them so that's pretty
cool now let's have a look at the actual
stream in architecture because we talked
about the data and we talked about the
storage
the streaming architecture this is a
very general overview of what the
architecture looks like we have data
coming from vendors it goes into a
real-time messaging bus
we have tick collectors that collect
those ticks they go into Kafka so Kafka
is something that we use internally to
to isolate us from downstream failures
then we have some tip processors on the
data eventually goes into tech stores
and version stores they it gets
available to both researchers and
trading strategies and produces trades
now ticks do originate on and on
exchanges as matt has mentioned but for
us for in all intents and purposes they
really come from data vendors we have we
have contracts with probably just about
data vendor out there they operating in
uniform format so they write adapters
for us sometimes we store their
appliances in our data centers so ticks
flow in a fairly uniform manner on to
our real-time messaging bus it's useful
you see there's a tech process over
there sometimes we subscribe directly to
it sometimes we use it for the rest of
the system but most of the time we put
them as fast as possible onto Kafka
because real-time messaging bus went it
goes it goes it doesn't stay there
tech collectors focus it's really that
purpose in life is just to collect the
text as fast as possible
they focus and they group them as as we
desire and then put them through onto
the Kafka bus for further use and Kafka
data is replayable Kafka data gets
stored if anything dies down stream from
Kafka we we can't bring it up so we have
a certain amount of leeway with what's
happening and then we also have tick
processes more tick processes do is not
not all the data that's required needs
to be are very high frequency so
obviously the tick date is extremely
high frequency and and researchers want
access to that and some of the life
processes need that frequency but but
most strategies don't so what we do is
processes usually down sample data one
our main units of down sampling is
one-minute bars they they pull the data
out and then republish the bond
bars onto CAF can't separate topics
market takes actual takes going to text
or gets available to researchers on the
downsample data goes into version store
together with any results of research
work and that becomes available to
trading strategies in actual production
and goes into life now as I said all
techs flow in a fairly uniform mana into
the real-time messaging bus that's up to
our data providers to make sure that it
takes our uniform as I said the right
adapters for us this is an example of
what goes into the real-time messaging
bus it's a tick you can see the type is
update it means it's a Delta from the
previous tick the alternative is an
image which shows you the whole snapshot
of all the fields you can see how the
data kind of matches to what Matt
discussed as a tech that we see on the
market so you can see they'd ask bid
price buy and everything else and other
other data that's relevant to the tick
and this changes a lot and we process
more than billion of these a day ok so
this is actually a screenshot of our
dashboard as something that we use in
the company this was one of the quieter
days you can see it's about 1.2 billion
ticks you can kind of see so that the
top the top bit is showing the text on
the kafka and you can see the quiet time
in the at night times then you could see
this is Asia opens and you can see
there's a little spike in text then we
have Europe that's bit more US open one
of the biggest spikes and actually one
of the largest mics is us closed when
everything everyone consolidates their
positions and then we have to handle
obviously the data flow in on the
regular basis but also handle the spikes
this one shows one-minute bars so one
minbars the processes that run with
smooth out the data you can see that
they don't need to run straightaway and
because date isn't Kafka we can just
come along spin up a process and do it
at our in our own time as long as they
become available when they need it and
the bottom bit is our [ __ ] storage so
it's 114th advice that's about 125 Tara
on this particular day
it's accumulative graph and that's
across all our environments it's kind of
going from dev environment or we don't
have much and it's going up on the top
to our the research environment on the
tech store our biggest users of data
okay I think yes so I will I'll give you
back to Matt and he will kind of look
into more detail on to the Kafka side of
the story and how the ticks so let's
talk about everything we have dick
collectors so yeah there's that only job
in life
it's a subscribe to the real-time
messaging bus they grab ticks off that
they package them in something we just
call it market data message structure um
well that does it just picks out it
picks out the symbol so the symbol is
probably going to be the name of the of
the actual security but the name of the
security may be the exchange ticker
something like Google without the e
the date the type so we get two types of
ticks essentially we either get update
ticks which just can tell it contain the
Delta of the order book as I described
before we also do get image ticks so
these contain all of the fields and just
tell you what the latest value for all
of the fields at a given point in time
is we saw the sequence number which we
get directly from the exchange which
ensures that we process ticks for a
given security in the correct order and
everything else we dump into data so
we're watching a lot of ticks to kafka
which one shard semi intelligently so
the way we do that is we try and char
the same way you effectively Africa does
so catechist scales chords on Tillie by
increasing the number of partitions per
topic and your whiting and reading
through these individual partitions each
tick collector is a java process which
has the same number of threads as we do
partitions we've hashed a symbol that so
that the Hatter the symbol then dictates
which Kefka partition it is going to be
written to and also which thread is
going to do the writing obviously we
need to use the same kind of hashing
with ontology on the lead path this is
the white path well this is quite useful
because it means if you know what subset
of symbols you want to start from
reading data from Kafka for you only
need to look in a subset of partitions
which means you don't necessary need to
process every single message that we've
written to caf-co for that topic
you kind of look out what I cross
section of one of the partitions looks
like it looks a little bit like this so
obviously you have update messages for a
number of given symbols and you have to
read them in sequence
if you only want data for example Google
not Microsoft and they both live in this
partition the downside to this is you
have to pick and choose which messages
you want and which messages you don't
cool so everything's on Kafka the
effectively only step remaining is to
dump everything among go for long-term
storage and such that trading strategies
can access it in production so most
takes flow straight through to
arctictech store which is a store
designed for tick level data as I said
we have two processors what they are
mostly doing here is that killing stuff
of Kafka there we something it's to be
of lower frequency I depict so it might
be one minute data terminal data
depending on the strategy andrey
publishing it back to Kafka that we pub
that we published effectively data frame
that goes back into Kafka is then going
to be written to object version store
and from there it's going to be made
available to the trading strategies so
we do use caf-co quite heavily we do
rely on it quite a lot I think good to
us it provides us I refer to as
infrastructural isolation effectively if
everything downtown Kafka dies it's not
the end of the world as long as we can
pick us up within a week which we can do
we're not going to lose any data if we
didn't have Kafka and everything went
down all the tics of photos in those
like real-time messaging bus would be
gone forever it's not disaster but we
don't want to lose data we want to verge
be able to try and retain as much as
possible also all of our we sampling
effectively happens by Kafka we take
things off Kafka we sample it we move up
we publish back to Kafka and then we can
use I do a standard application just to
copy it from card someone go and
obviously you get some of the advantages
that you get for normal message buses
are you can talk across languages we
have clients both in Java and Python
that allow us to do all of this yeah it
does trade-off latency for throughput
it's not a big deal for us to be honest
if it takes five seconds for a tick to
go all the way through the pipes be done
sampled within two Arctic and then for
the training strategy to pick it up
that's that's absolutely fine that in
itself is not an issue that's a good
trade-off as far as we are concerned
so let's have a just a quick look at
some of the api's basically for the
Kafka site as we said we have producers
who are producing in Java just because
it gives us the parallelism we can
assign as matt said we can assign each
thread per partition and we can write
things really fast now we're using
Apache Kafka on the Kafka clients maven
plugins they're just just available and
easy to use for crafter consumer side
that's Python so we use in Kafka Python
with a little bit of an internal magic
for size and extensions just just to
make the unpacking faster we use message
pack to encode all the data a message
pack is really easy it's what's really
that's all it takes to message pack and
message back out on the consumer sites
we have a fairly thin wrapper on the
consumer and it just it just basically
wraps it and provides lots of bit of
extra functionality that's an example
one of the functions we would use so for
example just to get time series you can
provide simple library date range
it feels you're interested in on the
host to read from and it's it uses their
Kafka's get messages API to get the
batch of messages and wrap them in a
Python data frame which is what our
researchers use unlike Arctic so Arctic
is another side of the story
Arctic again it's open source and you
can if you if you actually look at these
api's they're extremely simple and the
new Arctic Arctic native has exact all
the same interface so there's there's no
difference the only difference is so
arctic native something I forgot to
mention is as I said we can't
deteriorates than to using [ __ ] very
heavily we have made a step away from
that so at the moment we are supports an
LM DB for local storage local caching or
we just store results of your local
simulations we use [ __ ] as the first
classes and obviously we we have a lot
of data there and we use s3 so s3 is
kind of the future for us a lot of it
and it's it's proven to be quite good
and the idea in the future is to support
fully and
tear storage so data will flow through
different storages without the user
being aware all the way up to the
glacier store for data that nobody kind
of uses but I'm sure somebody in a
year's time will suddenly need that data
and you know the library will read it
for them
now again we kind of have this to get
time series function researchers love it
and use it it provides a lot of points
of customization so in the in the
easiest format you can say get time
series for the symbol from this library
that's it it does the work for you
there's other points of customization
you can filter on fields you can get
date ranges you can say you don't want
any duplicates to give you the snapshot
of data as off sometime in the past if
you're doing tests and filter holidays
various things and many more as a API
type of thing creating libraries is
almost identical so logical data stores
we don't we don't care you just provide
us the type and the magic happens so you
can use initialize library version data
it defaults the version stores that will
create a version store if you provide
library type text or that will create an
optimized text or that deals with sparse
data and stores and floats really well
for you and everything gets compressed
reading and writing it's what's real
just reading right again some of the
points of customizations you get in time
series are the same you know if you want
date range or some things like that
I'm good times it is a higher level
function that researchers can use and
that's top you can kind of see this is
an example of time series the
researchers will get outside of a
function for a particular symbol you get
just the x and then you get relevant
floats you have your px open open
high/low and the last so that's the tick
and yeah you might not have seen this
slide but yeah or maybe you seen this a
lot but that's that that is basically
our architecture you know it's it's it's
somewhat simple it's also complete not
of complete view by far it's a it's kind
of small glimpse and obviously we focus
on the data side and ingestion side but
I hope it gave you an idea of how tech
comes from vendors goes into real-time
messaging bars gets collected
stores and Kafka
a little bit of reliability and then we
can come at our own time and process and
downsample them store everything
absolutely everything for researchers
and store a subset for trading
strategies I think is it back to Matt no
it's back to me okay
so yes I I hope you kind of noticed that
I mean we are a fairly large fund we've
been trading for for a long time and we
have we have billions of a.m. you know
think about hundred billion and all of
that data is flowing through open-source
components so Kafka MongoDB our own open
source we use a lot of other open source
stuff inside we do love it we do embrace
it we have our own large repository and
keeps growing it's kind of like our
target to grow it move and give back to
the community he can you can just follow
it and have a look we also host buy data
and machine Lauren meetups in London
it's a monument you know they're free
you can come along and talk and chat and
see if there's there's anyone you you
know there's anything interest in there
there's also something we're gonna do
this year we've done it before it's an
open-source hackathon it's scheduled for
the 2nd of November it's gonna be 10
hours straight coding we've moved away
from the 24 hour session because it's
just a little bit difficult for when
you're in full-time employment to code
for 24 hours straight so save the date
well it's fun if you're doing it for
your own thing but I think it's harder
when somebody else's project so yeah
save the date and sign up and you know
camel ons be fun but what we do is we
invite contributors from open source
projects and you know you can join one
of the groups that you're most
interested in and just code with cool
people and you know solve some problem
on a day and maybe meet some peeps on
last year we hired contributors from
some part a cyber numpy Apache ro yeah
just people like that I'm gonna open the
floor to questions but you know if
there's anything else you can come to
our stands we are right outside and ask
us any more questions
okay idea I know you mentioned or you
shown one of the slides some data
visualization what do you use for that
sometimes more data visualization oh oh
you mean or get more muttering Isis it
bigger father
monitoring visualized oh yeah I do a lot
so just purely could have honor just
dies right nothing else and in terms of
your micro services or services you have
four collector and processors are these
ones package has local containers or yes
running wooden so everything is doctor
eyes running on the box we use a fairly
simple infrastructure doctor compose
effectively so we don't use kubernetes
okay location specify that and so
everything we're moving towards
containers we are driving to release not
but our production is still just don't
compose and kind of slightly in-house
way of yes and last one for real-time
processing what is what are you using
for one person real-time message you
that is a third-party message bus I do
not know if we're allowed to name it or
not I see okay then you can salsa I know
but okay noise
thanks for a really interesting talk
so in how long does data stay in Kafka
on average and what's the the process
like for getting data out of Kafka into
MongoDB DT of like Kefka connect sinks
and stuff like that or is it stuff you
written yourself
so it depends it depends what the data
vendor that we get at forum is it
depends how much data flows through that
particular pipe effectively because
everything in caffeine is configured to
store not on the length of time but for
certain amount of disk space so
obviously it depends how much data is
actually being stored there I think in
January between one and two weeks as
long as it's enough time for us to bear
to handle an outage that's what we care
about most and that's hopefully plenty
of time so now everything the pipeline
form Kafka through to Mungo is it's all
custom it's all in-house it's not
obviously massively complicated yeah
we're talking a lot of pain a little bit
of pain that's a fun question that's
fine
they work
hi there thank you for the talk I think
you may have just answered the question
but just wondering what's the process
like in patching your text or in case
you should drop messages in your
real-time messaging bus or you have an
experienced an outage but historical
data um for historical data we can grab
the data from the vendor if we've missed
a month's worth of data we can go back
to the vendor we can get it that way
that's painful generally so our first
port of call is simply not to miss any
data in the first place but if worse
comes to us if you know two years later
we find that as a particular research
team who have a strategy in mind and
they desperately need three months worth
of data that for whatever reason we're
missing we can get it but we'd prefer it
in the first place it's a bit of a patch
job obviously but it doesn't happen that
often plus for small blurbs there's
something called data completion so most
vendors provide data compiled for
conflation if you miss a couple of ticks
right a couple of milliseconds worth of
ticks
they will encode the data in the hey
yeah thanks for the presentation as well
just interested in the in your
performance and throughput charts you
will see some very high peak performance
they're interested what sort of
infrastructure you find that you need
for Kafka to to cover that sort of that
sort of demand that yeah so the peaks in
there are high so you may get three
billion messages and not in that day
obviously but on the peak times they'll
be much faster than the average of three
billion across a day yeah so you're
interesting what what what sort of setup
you need on Kefka to to make it handle
that it's nothing massively special
powerful books is obviously every topic
is your I get across eight different
partitions so the actual calcio topic
itself is across a few different boxes
we don't use the morph of meeting
actually than writing we try and do
things in pytho as much as possible
as throughput in Python and so on the
when we take things off Kafka we don't
decode them to the wall form in Python
because certain extensions will do that
for us I mean that honestly it's it's
nothing particularly special or
innovative sometimes we do get backed up
it's not the end of the world because as
you can see inter throughput is not
constant I think it's coming though
if it was if it was kind of peak all the
way through yes we need a different
infrastructure it's happily not peak all
the way it's basically horizontal
scaling you know just just keeping it
elastic I said we're doing it through
powerful hardware and basically running
up Charlotte as a matter of fact I think
eight is a typical partition car but for
very heavy feats we have up to 32
partitions and they cost the data
together so ultimately you have you know
you have lots of processes running we
have lots of threads each thread per
partition it's not that bad it's durable
I thank you for the talk my question is
about a data reliability reliability
yeah and kafka level it is understand
and understood that Kafka can handle it
but how do you handle that at real-time
message bus how do you ensure that the
data is not lost or it's not duplicated
or needs to be processed at real-time
bus message bus because I see everything
depends on the data for you and it need
you need to make sure that the data is
right and the you expect what is coming
we have no we're even sure if we have
missed something there is no way so off
the wheels iMessage bus if you have
missed something unfortunately we know
obviously when we are placing less
messages than we expect to for given
point of time you know how many messages
we should be processing I think one
point of time on a weekday
it's only we see 50% of that you have to
take a look but if we do drop a message
it does happen but on the real-time
message bus we
we effectively fill our buffers and we
have to drop a few thousand messages it
has happened it's not the end of the
world as long as we're up and running as
quickly as possible
I say we're not high-frequency traders
so you know we can't deal with a little
bit of naught plus there's a lotta bit
of redundancy in the data I think we
haven't actually touched on that but we
are subscribing to a lot of data that's
the same but from different providers so
sometimes we can't control it right we
had a pipe going down from one of the
providers that is simply not flowing in
our system notices that the data has
stopped and switches to a different
provider so we have our preferred
providers from which we always take the
data but if they go down or if the
number of texts reduces then you know
pipes
pipe section will get caught by people
by engineers which we happens by
literally so yes we just wished a
different provider data might be
slightly of lower quality but we still
ensure that the data flows through the
system
I think the tech poster so that we
didn't go over on the right it's meant
to be kind of stream wet so if one goes
down it knows exactly which one to pick
up next
it actually individually looks at the
fields decide which one is most suitable
to take highest priority if all of them
up but we try mean fairly intelligent if
it does go down which does happen hi
guys
great talk and you mentioned the
beginning Europe and a medium to low
frequency traders so why do you deem it
necessary to collect your data at such a
fine granularity
or just because we're medium to low
frequency traders doesn't mean we don't
want to be able to store everything over
time to identify trades where possible
or to identify strategies where possible
so when we talk about medium to low
we're saying that's the speed at which
we trade over the length of time with
all the positions for obviously the data
that goes into making the decision
should be us I mean that doesn't change
because you need to have the most the
best fidelity and about the best view of
the world when you come to make in that
decision and we are making that decision
not as humans but as computers which
means you know we are also accountable
our algorithms are accountable
essentially so it doesn't change what
comes into the system it just changes
the frequency at which it flows out of
the system that's not really you know
it's not really a question and all of us
no matter which frequency trading where
and all of us will be storing and
collecting this data we have time for
one more question everybody hi thank you
for the talk once more in terms of your
open source project do you do you see
people who are not actively involved
with man group to contribute to them and
is it a big amount of people it's
footwork what we do sometimes it's not a
huge amount of people are the firm's do
use it Arctic in particular to factory
data frames for it is very useful for
that I don't know exactly how many
external contributors we have how many
stars do we have do you know people it's
kind of people who start using the
defined useful they keep using it
we it's extremely useful to us
internally so it's not something we ever
gonna drop plus was Arctic native I
think that the adoption would be higher
because it's it's quite smart couple of
published some papers about it we've
implements the whole thing internally it
aims to solve a problem that hasn't
really been solved before you know a
versioned access to data so data is
audits and data can also be rebound
based in the day
so I think that that will get her a wide
adoption I mean Arctic is itself is
mature software every bit of I'd have
quantitative time series data at the
entire company is stored using Arctic
and the entire company yeah on its
ability to store then accesses yeah
thank you very much cool let's give them
a round of applause please
[Applause]